hi guys hi girls this is Luca and this  is a very short video to tell you that  on the 31st of August Saturday at 9 p.m.  at the screen in Berlin there's a very  cool event that is going to take place  and this event will see a lot of a  famous language youtubers and  instagramers were gonna gather there to  meet and greet their fans so there's you  know apart from our very same very own  Gabriel Gelman aka organizer of this  amazing event  one of the organizers that we're gonna  have people like learning English with  Lucy's super holiday Lina baskets you  name it this is a very cool event if you  happen to be in Berlin you should  definitely come I will find a lot of  information in the on the link by  clicking on the link in the description  box and I will be waiting with you there  with a lot of other youtubers thanks and  see you soon